I was in Lagos Nigeria in 2014 when I
heard about five young men in the north
of the country who faced the death
penalty for committing Gay X they were
in the Sharia law controlled private
part of the country so I went up to see
them fortunately by the time I got up
there their case had been dismissed and
they were out of prison but they were
homeless and they were very afraid and
meeting them was was really difficult
eventually I convinced them that it was
safe and they they came to my hotel to
meet me and I you know heard each of
their stories and that's where I met
young Boo Jane so I was deeply moved by
these stories of survival and that's
when I started I left northern Nigeria
and started where love is illegal so I
documented these stories of survival you
know people who'd survived persecution
from around the world people who've
survived in prison imprisonment and
violent attack and attempted murder and
rape people who've been ostracized by
their family members who fled their
countries who've done all they can to
hide who they are because they didn't
were not considered by their community
as normal I told the stories of 77
different people from 16 different
nationalities many of the people I met
were afraid to have their stories told
this is Sally she is afraid to show your
face because in Syria the so-called
Islamic state hunting down gay and trans
people they want her dead because she
identifies as a woman the Islamic state
don't want you to hear her story and
this is J&Q from uganda they're hiding
their faces because they are a lesbian
couple and they fear their community
their community doesn't want you to hear
their story and this is Eve from
Cameroon and Eve is hiding his face
because that country arrests more gay
men just for being gay than any other
country in the continent those arresting
and torturing the gaming of Cameroon do
not want you to hear his story but the
reason that these people are here on the
screen behind me is that they want this
story hood and they shared it because
they hope that by doing so that their
situation might change for themselves
and for people like them
but for some of course a photo poses a
risk for some if they are identified
they could face further persecution well
it could even be killed but many of them
wanted to share their stories and I was
really desperate to tell them but the
only way that was going to be possible
was if it was done on their terms when I
met the young man in northern Nigeria at
the time I was in Lagos Nigeria and I
was shooting a story for National
Geographic and I was using a large
format camera and a Polaroid type film
for those who not familiar with a large
format camera it's a it's a big camera
and it has bellows at the front and in a
glass plate and you have to put your
head under a hood to see everything
upside down and the wrong way it's not
an easy process but you know as
photographing these portraits with this
Polaroid film and I and I wanted to
continue it with this work initially I
thought I'd continue with this work
because I you know it was an aesthetic
decision I like the look of it but I
actually took on a I think an even more
important purpose I gave each of the
people that I photographed the option to
destroy the picture if they felt that it
somehow endangered them so and I think
that they promise you know to put their
hand over the picture and let them take
it and destroy it was a real aid and
building trust but I didn't have to just
destroy many and intercept because from
the outset I adopted a new way of
working these photographs were going to
be a collaboration initially that was a
you know and I had it was it was that
the terms of the agreement was that I
had to had to make it this do it this
way but it's a very different way of
working because usually as photographers
we like to control every you know we
kind of control freaks we like to
control every aspect of the shoot but
here I was handing over control to the
subjects themselves and I was allowing
them to choose what they would wear how
they would pose and how they would
express themselves and of course how
much of their face they wanted to show I
also wanted them to tell their own
stories and in their own words so ask
each of them to
right their own testimony which would
accompany their photographs and when we
share their testimonies on on the
website we always you know quite the
mess with idli directly and here for
many of them for the first time they had
control over how they were seen and how
they were heard but of course handing
over control meant that there were
sometimes some unexpected results and
tell you the story about a young
transgender woman Jessie she lives in a
Palestinian refugee camp in Lebanon and
her young life has been this what one of
extreme hardship she's been bullied and
thrown out of school she has been raped
and most shockingly her brother and
father in order to protect the family
honor Heather on several occasions
attempted to murder her her story was
this list of horrendous abuses and
instinctively I wanted to make a
photograph that reflected that story but
she didn't so we start the session and I
find a corner of a room of some nice
light and I set up my camera on the
tripod and you know this is big camera
and I wind out the bellows and I put the
lens on the front and I have my my
cassette film i shutter my cape I asked
her to come into the end of the frame
and she covers her face below these
large dark eyes with a scarf in order to
protect her identity
and she starts posing and she pushes out
her buttock and she tilts up her head
and starts to seduce the camera with her
eyes and I looked through the frame and
I think this is not the photograph I
plan to take but but she is beautiful
and from the camera and strong and
empowered and I had to remind myself
that you know I was having to give over
control as I was to let her allow her to
portray herself as she would like so
despite this photograph not matching her
story I decided to take the pictures
anyway then afterwards we were talking
about herstory some more and she's
continued to explain the situation with
her family and you know she's daily at
grave risk of being murdered by her own
her own flesh and blood and you know I
listened to her and I said look I
understand that you identify as a woman
but given the threats that you face
wouldn't it just be better to pretend to
be a boy and she looked up at me in a
shock and she said I was born this way
and I will die this way and in that
moment I understood her gender identity
is fundamental to who she is I've never
had my identity challenged she's
threatened every day because of how she
presents herself with that statement
I understood just his courage and her
strength and her photograph was perfect
this is her story she sees herself as a
beautiful young woman a sexy young woman
and that is who she wants you to see
what happened to her is not who she is
so I have this belief and that is that
storytelling is fundamental to the human
experience is how we communicate with
each other and it's even how we
communicate with ourselves but of course
the types of stories that we tell are
really important and there are stories
that connect and there are stories that
divide and I think you know I this also
this belief that you know to look for
difference in each other is a is a
natural human instinct and that
sometimes and for some of us in order to
feel like we belong we sometimes also
feel this need to exclude so I've been
trying to tell what I'm calling
authentic personal stories which stories
that come just as much from the people
on photographing as they do for myself
where their point of view their voice
and their vision is included in the
construction of the picture so I have
this belief also that these these
authentic personal stories have great
power to break down these barriers that
divide us barriers of race and religion
and nationality and gender and sexuality
and I really hope that they help us to
see
the person are not just a label and it's
my hope that in seeing the person we can
see you know what connects us so I
believe that we need more stories that
connect but this work actually is a
testament to the destructive power of
the other kind of stories divisive
stories allow the casual discrimination
of LGBT people and divisive stories also
allow for their rape and their torture
and their murder so what happens when
all there is is the voice of hate
bigotry thrives with those discriminated
against a silenced where they are
disallowed the right to tell their own
stories and this is repeated time and
time again throughout history with every
human rights issue where loves illegal
is made to interrupt the narrative that
to be LGBT is an attack on society
against nature or an insult to God it is
made to amplify the voices of survivors
of discrimination and allow them to have
their stories heard stories that I
believe can connect and stories that I
believe can help us to empathize so I
spent a year documenting these stories
of survival and the next important step
was to make sure that they were heard I
wanted to reach the widest audience
possible and I want that audience to
feel like they could do more than just
read the story but they could be in some
way involved so I created some social
media accounts and I created a website
and I started sharing these stories
online but then I also invited other
people from the LGBT community to share
their own story so it wasn't just about
my photographs all those stories that I
recorded
but people from around the world were
able to use new this platform that that
I've created and we started getting
stories from coming in from all over the
place from Italy from Israel from Iran
Venezuela Australia United States Jordan
South Africa Kuwait South Korea and many
many other places and the goal was to
create this global voice of people who
refuse to be silenced by bigotry now
these voices I'm proud to say you know
have now reached millions around the
world so many of the people that I met
while doing this work spoke of how alone
they felt how they grew up in societies
that told them that who they are is
wrong and in these environments when all
one hears is the voice of intolerance
many sadly believed it but as bandwidths
continue to grow in technology spreads
so does the voice of these once hidden
stories social media remarkably allows
people to connect in some cases feel
less alone and in this context it is
really as a remarkable tool because it's
allowing people who otherwise would
struggle to be heard to have a platform
to have their to be hood so in the first
three months we had a hundred thousand
followers on Instagram and the support
was really overwhelming and there's a
National Geographic contributing
photographer I was able to post on the
National Geographic Instagram site so
you know for this picture alone we had
240,000 people like it you know and
given that our goal was to amplify the
voices of those peoples silenced by
bigotry social media was really giving
us a helping hand but it wasn't just a
you know online that we were creating
this work we and sorry it wasn't just my
my photographs
it was photographs from the other people
sharing their stories too for as an
example as CJ who is here from the US CJ
is from a Christian family she lives in
a very conservative area CJ was drugged
and gang-raped by four young men she was
semi-conscious during the rape and
remembers wanting them one of them
telling her
that he was saving her from burning
eternally in hell CJ is a lesbian CJ
told us that you know she was it was
very liberating for her to share her
story but she also talked about how she
still felt a deep level of shame we were
flooded with comments of love and
support for CJ and many people including
myself and the volunteers that were
lovers illegal were deeply moved by her
story again social media was allowing
people to connect but the impact is not
just online and we've been having this
work you know go into traditional media
and into exhibitions and from in many
different countries and it's just a you
know the many different ways and
platforms that we are able to have these
voices heard including things like doing
talks like this but as I said earlier
raising awareness is not enough so with
some volunteers I created this
organization witness change which is a
501 C 3 and you know some volunteers
came forward some of them are not here
tonight which is very nice and impact
became a major driver in the work that
we do and we keep asking ourselves where
is the change in what we're doing how
are we making a difference and we wanted
to make sure that we're getting the work
in front of people who could really make
a difference in giving them avenues to
make change happen so and that's what
we've been doing so in every country
where I worked
I would collaborate with a small
organization grassroots organization or
a couple of people who are working with
the LGBT community and we thought okay
if we can help to support them some of
them who are very poorly resourced that
would be making a difference so we
raised some money and we supported an
organization in South Africa who are
helping LGBT refugees and we raised the
money we helped it helped a organisation
in Uganda who are tackling homophobic
attitudes and when the
young guys who helped me in northern
Nigeria when they reached out to me and
said this for young men who have been
arrested for committing gay acts and
they are in prison and we don't have
bail we can't afford legal
representation so we turned to social
media and we posted this and within 24
hours we raised the money to get the
bail and enough money to get them legal
representation so we got them out of
prison and the lawyers got the charges
dropped so you know where love is legal
has not by any stretch changed the world
for LGBT people but for these four year
it really made a world of difference
[Music]
Oh